on attendait une hausse importante des
prix à la consommation au mois de mai
elle est encore plus élevé que prévu
7,7 pour cent au canada du jamais vu
depuis 1983 et 7,5 pour cent au québec
association qui est sérieuse qui impacte
tous les québécois le prix de l'essence
à la pompe a largement contribué à cette
hausse tout comme le panier d'épicerie
on regarde beaucoup beaucoup les
spéciaux puis on y va selon les besoins
on n'achète pas trop on prépare les
menus davance je pense que les gens font
ce qu'ils peuvent les salaires
augmentent pas en même temps que
l'inflation mais le pays pourraient être
bientôt derrière nous espère le ministre
girard normalement le sommet de
l'inflation et anticipé la au tour de me
joins au deuxième trimestre à partir du
6 ou devrait voir une douce descente
devant l'inflation galopante québec veut
d'abord soulagé les consommateurs je me
fie à un sondage qui est paru ce matin
les québécois ont là de penser que les
baisses d'impôts puis les chèque qu'on
envoie sont les bons moyens
ailleurs dans le monde chacun a sa
recette pour combattre la spirale
inflationniste en espagne où l'inflation
atteint 8,7 pour cent on a choisi
d'abaisser les taxes sur l'énergie et de
protéger les entreprises
au royaume uni on a brisé un record
vieux de 40 ans et le gouvernement
annoncé l'équivalent de 60 milliards de
dollars canadiens en soutien aux
familles
chez nos voisins une nourrice à sion est
sur toutes les lèvres le gouvernement
baden élimine pour trois mois la taxe
fédérale sur l'essence demande au
gouverneur de faire la même chose y met
les compagnies pétrolières ou des filles
selon les spécialistes le déconfinement
progressive de la chine devrait
également permettre de soulager
l'économie mondiale les normands grondin
radio canada montréal